رغم الازمه السياسيه والاقتصاديه الخارقه
التي تعيشها تعمل ايران على اعاده احياء
مشروعا التوسعي قرب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
مشروع طرطره روسيا بحرب اوكرانيا وترضي
الاوضاع المعيشيه في سوريا يشكلان فرصه
ثانيه
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
لتنفيذ هدفها تستعين طهران بشراء المنازل
واقامه معسكرات جديده في منطقه ملاصقه
لمناطق نفوذ روسيا المشغوله بحربها في
اوكرانيا ريف دمشق الجنوب الشرقي يضم
الكثير من البلدات والقرى تتبع اداريا
محافظه
كيلومترات مربع يحده من الشمال مخيم
اليرموك للاجئين الفلسطينيين وحيوا
التضامن ومن الشمال الشرقي حيا سيدي مقداد
والقزاز ومن الجنوب منطقه السيده زينب
التي تسيطر عليها ايرانيه ومن الشرق غوطه
دمشق الشرقيه ومن الغرب حي الحجر الاسود
منطقه السيده زينب على بعد نحوي ثمانيه
كيلومترات من العاصمه دمشق المعقل الرئيسي
للمليشيات الايرانيه والفصائل المواليه
التي يزيد عددها على 50 فاصيلا و60 الف
مسلح يعملون تحت قياده خبراء عسكريين
ايرانيين على تنفيذ مساعد
تماما مثل ما فعلت في الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت حسب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط